right now beneath a shimmering blue sea
millions of fish are having sex and the
way they're doing it and strategies
they're using looks nothing like what we
see on land take parrotfish in this
species all fish are born female and
they look like this then later in life
she can transition into a male and
she'll look like this but it's not just
a spectacular wardrobe change her body
can reabsorb her ovaries and grow testes
in their place in just a few weeks
she'll go from making eggs to producing
sperm it's pretty impressive and in the
ocean it's also pretty common in fact I
bet nearly all of you have at some point
had a seafood dish made up of an
individual that started life as one sex
and transitioned to another oysters
grouper shrimp seeing some heads nodding
yeah but not all fish that's changed
sexes start as females those clownfish
we know from Finding Nemo they're all
born male so in the real world when
Nemo's mother died Nemo's dad Marlin
would have transitioned into Marlene and
Nima would have likely mated with his
father turned mother you can see
you can see why Pixar took a little
creative license with the plotline right
so sex change in the ocean can happen in
either direction and sometimes even back
and forth and that's just one of the
many amazing strategies animals used to
reproduce in the ocean and trust me when
I say is one of the least surprising sex
in the sea is fascinating and it's also
really important and not just too nerdy
marine biologists like me who are
obsessed with understanding these salty
Affairs it matters for all of us today
we depend on wild-caught fish to help
feed over 2 billion people on the planet
we need millions of oysters and corals
to build the giant reefs that protect
our shorelines from rising seas and
storms we depend on medicines that are
found in marine animals to fight cancer
and other diseases and for many of us
the diversity and beauty of the oceans
is where we turn for recreation and
relaxation and our cultural heritage in
order for us to continue to benefit from
the abundance that ocean life provides
the fish in coral and shrimp of today
have to be able to make fish and shrimp
and coral for tomorrow to do that they
have to have lots and lots of sex and
until recently we really didn't know how
sex happened in the sea it's pretty hard
to study but thanks to new science and
technology we now know so much more than
even just a few years ago and these new
discoveries are showing two things first
sex in the sea is really funky second
our actions are wreaking havoc on the
sex lives of everything from shrimp to
salmon I know it can be hard to believe
so today I'm going to share a few
details about how animals do it in the
deep how we may be interrupting these
intimate affairs and what we can do to
change that
so remember those sex changing fish
in many places in the world we have
fishing rules that set a minimum catch
size fishers are not allowed to target
tiny fish this allows baby fish to grow
and reproduce before they're caught
that's a good thing
so Fisher's go after the biggest fish
but in parrotfish for example or any sex
changer targeting the big fish means
that they're taking out all the males
that makes it hard for a female fish to
find a mate or it forces her to change
sexes sooner at a smaller size both of
these things can result in fewer fish
babies in the future
in order for us to properly care for
these species we have to know if they
change sexes how and when only then can
we create rules that can support these
sexual strategies such as setting a
maximum size limit in addition to a
minimum one the challenge isn't that we
can't think of these sex friendly
solutions the challenge is knowing which
solutions to apply to which species
because even animals we know really well
surprise us when it comes to their sex
lives take Maine lobster they don't look
that romantic or that kinky
they are both
during mating season female lobsters
want to mate with the biggest baddest
males but these guys are really
aggressive and they'll attack any
lobster that approaches male or female
meanwhile the best time for her to mate
with the male is right after she's
molted when she's lost her hard shell so
she has to approach this aggressive guy
in her most vulnerable state what's a
girl to do
her answer spray him in the face
repeatedly with her urine under the sea
pee is a very powerful love potion
conveniently lobsters bladders sit just
above their brains and they have two
nozzles under their I stock which which
they can shoot their urine forwards so
the female approaches the male's den and
as he charges out she lets loose a
stream of urine and then gets the hell
out of there only a few days of this
daily dosing is all it takes for her
scent to have a transformative effect
the male turns from an aggressive to a
gentle lover by the week's end
he invites her into his den after that
the sex is easy so how are we
interrupting this kind of kinky
courtship well the female's urine
carries a critical chemical signal that
works because it can pass through
seawater and lobsters have a smell
receptor that can detect and receive the
message climate change is making our
oceans more acidic it's the result of
too much carbon dioxide entering
seawater this change in chemistry could
scramble that message or it could damage
the lobster smell receptors pollution
from land can have similar impacts
just imagine the consequence for that
female if her love potion should fail
these are the kinds of subtle but
significant impacts were having on the
love lives of these marine lights and
this is a species we know well lobsters
live near shore in the
shallows dive deeper and sex gets even
stranger fan fin angler fish live at
about 3,000 feet below the surface in
the pitch-black waters and the males are
born without the ability to feed
themselves to survive he has to find a
female fast
meanwhile the female who is 10 times
bigger than the male 10 times she lets
out a very strong pheromone
with which to attract mates to her so
this tiny male is swimming through the
black waters smelling his way to a
female and when he finds her he gives
her a love bite and this is when things
get really weird that love bite triggers
a chemical reaction whereby his jaw bone
starts to disintegrate his face melts
into her flesh and their two bodies
start to fuse their circulatory systems
entwine and all his internal organs
start to dissolve except for his testes
his testes mature just fine and start
producing sperm in the end he's
basically a permanently attached
on-demand sperm factory for the female
it's a very efficient system but this is
not the kind of mating strategy that we
see on a farm right I mean this is weird
it's really strange but if we don't know
that these kind of strategies exist or
how they work we can't know what kind of
impacts we may be having even in the
deep sea just three years ago we
discovered a new species of deep-sea
octopus where the females lay their eggs
on sponges attached to rocks that are
over two and a half miles deep
these rocks contain rare earth minerals
and right now there are companies that
are building bulldozers that would be
capable of mining the deep sea floor for
those rocks but the bulldozers would
scrape up all the sponges and all the
eggs with them
knowingly and in many cases unknowingly
we are preventing successful sex and
reproduction in the deep and let's be
honest
dating and mating is hard enough without
somebody coming in and interrupting all
the time right I mean we know this so
today well I hope you will leave here
with some excellent bar trivia on fish
sex I also ask that you remember this we
are all far more intimately connected
with the oceans than we realize no
matter where we live and this level of
intimacy requires a new kind of
relationship with the ocean one that
recognizes and respects the enormous
diversity of life and its limitations we
can no longer think of the oceans as
just something out there because every
day we depend on them for our food
security our own health and wellness and
every other breath we take but it is a
two-way relationship and the oceans can
only continue to provide for us if we in
turn safeguard that fundamental force of
life in the sea sex and reproduction so
like any relationship we have to embrace
some change for the partnership to work
the next time you're thinking about
having seafood look for sustainably
caught or farmed species that are local
and low on the food chain these are
animals like oysters clams mussels small
fish like mackerel these all reproduce
like crazy and with good management they
can handle a bit of fishing pressure we
can also rethink what we use to wash our
bodies clean our homes and care for our
lawns all those chemicals eventually
wash out to sea and disrupt the natural
chemistry of the ocean industry also has
to play its part and take a
precautionary approach protecting sexual
activity where we know it exists and
preventing harm in the cases where we
just don't yet know enough like the deep
sea
and in the communities where we live the
places we work and the country in which
we vote we must take bold action on
climate change now
[Applause]